-My first guest
is a 17-time WWE champion
and one of the biggest
movie stars in the world.
Now his life is the subject
of a new NBC comedy series
called "Young Rock,"
which premieres
February 16th at 8:00 p.m.
Here's the one and only
Dwayne Johnson.
Ha ha!
It's the stud right there.
That's what I'm talking about.
-My man.
-That is what I'm talking about.
-Good to see you, brother.
-It is great to see you, man.
You look great.
You dedicate 100%
to every single thing you do,
and that's what
I love about you,
but you've always done that
since I've known you.
Your new tequila, Teremana.
By the way,
it is unbelievably delicious.
That is a fantastic tequila.
-Thank you, man.
-It is unbelievable.
I remember when
you first launched it,
I go,
"Dude, let's try this stuff."
It's my favorite.
It's unbelievable.
-Yeah. I sent you some.
-Dude, it's empty. It's done.
It's an empty box. It's great.
But you broke records
in its first year of business.
-It was -- It was --
It was incredible.
We wound up becoming --
We wound up breaking --
We wound up being the first --
the biggest launch
in the history of all spirits,
and that's all spirits
across the board.
That's vodka, that's whiskey,
it's rum, it's -- it's gin.
It was absolutely incredible.
-Yes!
-And to give you
a little bit of context,
we wound up selling
in less than a year
over 300,000 nine-liter cases.
And when George Clooney
sold his tequila line,
they were selling about 160,000.
And we sold 300,000
in less than a year.
I mean, it's just --
it's really crazy.
But I got to tell you
something, you know.
As you said, you do everything
like you do anything,
and that's with 100% commitment.
I wanted to make
good-quality tequila
for people
and bring people together.
I wanted to make the tequila
for the people.
-Good for you. I love it.
I want to talk about
the show about your life.
Let's talk about "Young Rock."
It premieres next Tuesday
here on NBC.
Was it you who realized
that your life could be a show?
Or did someone else
bring the idea to you
and you go, "Eh, could be"?
-You -- You know, there's guys
who I work very closely with
who you've met in the past,
as we're all buddies.
And it --
I would travel with these guys
all across the country.
And everywhere we would go --
and this is back
when I was wrestling.
And I would wrestle
in a different town every night.
We would all travel together.
And every time we would land,
every major city
across the country
I would say, "Yeah, you know,
see that gas station over there?
Well, you know,
that's where I bought
my first car from a crackhead."
"What?" "Yep."
And then the next town
we would go to, like,
"Yeah, you see that Motel 6?
Well, here's what
happened there."
So all these stories --
Finally, you know --
we started thinking,
"Well, I wonder...
creating a show
that has the lens of comedy
but to be able to share
the life lessons I've learned."
-You have three different actors
playing you
at the age of 10, 15, and 18.
You also appear as yourself
in the year 2032
running for president.
[ Laughter ]
Don't ever change, dude.
Please promise me.
Just don't ever change.
It is so fun.
It is so fun to watch everything
you do, man. I love it.
How did you decide that you
would tell the story that way?
-You know, it was --
Our show creator,
Nahnatchka Khan,
who's just such
a brilliant woman.
We were trying
to figure out a way --
Well, first of all,
we wanted to figure out
three points of my life
that were defining times.
When I was 10 years old,
living here in Hawaii...
when I was 15 years old,
after multiple arrests
and doing a lot of things
I shouldn't have been doing...
and then when
I was 18 years old,
when I started to get my life
a little bit back on track,
going to
the University of Miami.
Then she had said,
"Well, ultimately the audience
is going to want to see you.
What's the creative way that we
can infuse you into the show?"
So we sat for a few weeks.
And it was her.
She came up with the idea.
She said, "Well,
what if we set it in 2032
and you're running
for president?"
And I said, "I don't know.
It feels a little political."
She goes, "Well, there might be
a few people who might want
to see you run for president,
so think about it."
So I went home.
I talked to Lauren.
As you and I do, we go home,
we talk to our wives.
-That's it.
-Lauren said,
"I think you should do it.
I think it's great."
-That's the final stamp
you need.
Also, the actors
who portray your parents
on the show are great.
And you know I love your mom,
and I was gonna ask you --
-She loves you, by the way.
-Did your mom weigh in on
casting for who should play her?
-She wanted to know --
I told her.
I said, "Listen.
You're in good hands.
I'm gonna cast someone
who I think you're really
gonna be really happy with."
And I said, "Mom, but just keep
in mind, we have to -- let's --
We have to be authentic
with our casting.
I want to make sure
that there's a woman
who is of Polynesian descent,
maybe Samoan descent."
She said, "Absolutely. I know
exactly who you should cast."
I said, "Who?"
She goes, "J.Lo."
Well...hold on.
[ Laughter ]
-Dude, my mom did the same --
I did a movie
where, in a flashback, my mom
was Sharon Stone in a movie.
And my mom told everyone that --
She's like,
"Finally, someone did it right!
They cast Sharon Stone..."
[ Laughter ]
It's like -- Unbelievable.
It was so -- It's just the best.
I just saw a video.
You know, I love
watching your Instagrams.
And there was a video that
you posted that was beautiful.
And it was you and your mom
sitting at the headstone
of your grandparents in Hawaii
and singing this beautiful song.
But your mom played
great ukulele.
And I go, "Wait. What?!"
I did not know
that she could play --
Your mom plays the ukulele?
-Oh, yes. She is -- She --
Hey.
Get my mom really quickly and
tell her to bring the ukulele.
It's right there
on the inside of the door.
-What? Does she --
-Mom!
No. Get the ukulele.
-Okay. Got it.
-Is your mom there?
-She's right here.
Here. Come here.
Okay. Good. Put that down.
-Yeah.
-Okay. Come here. Come here.
I want you to say hello
to somebody you know.
-Who? Ohh!
-It's Jimmy Fallon.
-Hi! Oh, my gosh!
Mom, you're gorgeous!
So good -- Good to see you.
-Do you remember me?
-Are you kidd--
From our bit. New Year's.
Happy New Year.
I remember our bit.
-I know. I know.
Do you remember what you did?
[ Laughter ]
-Dude, I remember laying --
I remember laying on the ground
pretending I was passed out.
-I know.
-We were holding empty --
-That was awesome.
-We were holding empty bottles
of champagne.
Oh, you were so funny.
-We had the best time.
-That was the best.
-Lauren's mom and I, we had
the best time that night.
-Dude. And she constantly --
-We didn't expect you.
We didn't know you were going
to be there with your wife.
-She called me. "Jimmy's here,
and we're doing this!"
I was like, "Okay, Ma.
Tell him I said hello.
But come on. Don't bother him.
Don't bother Jimmy."
-We had so much fun.
-I said, "Okay, I won't."
-No, no.
Honestly, seriously, Dwayne,
your mom was fantastic.
She was so --
-We had a good time.
-We had the best time.
But I just want --
I was just talking about you
playing the ukulele.
Did not know that
you played the ukulele.
Obviously,
how would I guess this?
-He was asking -- When we went
to visit Grandma and Grandpa --
-Oh, did you see that?
-It was the most beautiful --
-I told him that --
-Every time we come to Hawaii,
we go up to visit
my parents, yeah.
-It was beautiful.
-She has -- Let's --
-I have mu ukulele.
-I know.
-Let's sing him a song
real quick. Go ahead.
-Okay, okay, okay. I got a song.
♪♪
-Oh. Sure. Okay.
-Okay.
♪♪
♪ Savalivali means
go for a walk ♪
♪ Tautalatala means
too much talk ♪
♪ Alofa ia te oe
means I love you ♪
♪ Take it easy, faifai lemu ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my goodness! Come on!
Are you joking me?!
-We have one more.
-No, we don't have one more!
what do you mean,
we have one more?
What is this? What's happening?
♪♪
-♪ We love you, Jimmy,
oh, yes, we do ♪
-Okay. I'll go with it.
♪ We love you, Jimmy,
and that is true ♪
♪ When we're away from you ♪
♪ We're blue ♪
♪ Oh, Jimmy, we love you ♪
-Oh, my! I love you!
-Good job, Mom. Good job.
-I'm sending love
right back to you.
Mom just crushed, by the way!
You just stole the interview.
You're unbelievable.
You are a superstar.
-I love when she goes --
I love when she goes,
"We got one more!"
I'm like, "What? We do?"
"We love you, Jimmy!"
-That was unbelievable.
-Good to see you, Jimmy.
-You're gorgeous.
It's great to see you.
And, yeah, happy new year again.
Let's do it again.
Guys, come on back.
We have more "Tonight Show"
when we come back.
Come on. We're going to talk
"Young Rock."
-Say hi to your lovely wife.
-I will.
-Leave, Ma!
-Okay.
-[ Laughter ]
-Mwah!